servus es geht sind herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ich war ja die
letzten zwei tage in paris
deswegen kam keine videos heute oft
gefragt welches video ihr euch heute
wünschen würde und es casey theater hat
vorgeschlagen dass wir einen cnet uk
machen soll von uni gemacht deswegen
wollte einen ersten versuch ist vor
circa einer stunde war die funktion als
das netz senden kann deaktiviert das
heißt ja jetzt erst mal die möglichkeit
apps zu senden und ich bin sehr gespannt
was dabei raus kann wenn dies erst jetzt
einfach ihr so auf dem handy zeigen sich
keine ahnung ob ich die runterladen
könnt dann ist premiere ziehen wenn ihr
wisst wie das geld könnte man die
kommentare stand steht meine mutter wird
irgendwas oben steht max dabei
irgendetwas leuten eben niemals im
wohnzimmer auf ja so alles klar die
erste nachricht stammt von kuschel
bescheuert mal ein was der kuschel bei
uns zeigen wird
was sind lebewesen ist das hatte es ist
ein hamster das so weit jetzt hier wo
kein job nie wann kommt eigentlich der
murger ich meine irgendwann solltest du
das auch mal schaffen oder nicht
ja es gibt momentan nicht wirklich voran
wir gucken momentaner lassen welches
tolles vertreiben könnte welches mädchen
dass anbieter das vertreiben könnte ich
mein netzwerk zusammen nach und es geht
momentan gar nicht so sehr an oder
ehrlich gesagt sagen weil ich somit ein
paar details ich zufrieden bin und die
die aber anders weil ein bisschen
tracking geben die hoffnung nicht auf
dass es 2016 kommt auch nicht wollte
könnte ich zu kanal ok der nächste snap
stammt von xxxx nicht lernen warst du
schon sagst du überall hin
ok welche länder war schon mal und wo
möchte ich will noch mal
ich war schon in salt man england
spanien italien frankreich indien belegt
arabische emirate den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten da in abu dhabi wenn
ich durch geflogen auf dem weg nach
indien weil ich ja man indien einen
monat lang praktikum gemacht hat die kpt
es ist waren und es würde es eine
einzelne packung 48 grad unterschritten
es schmeckt gut so als wäre es die
banane hörte ich weiß ja nicht was ich
euch vorstellt aber ich persönlich als
youtube findet ein bisschen komisch wenn
meine zuschauer mir schreiben dass ich
gut schmecke ich meine meine fragen
können okay ist cool videos oder du hast
einen zopf schneider jahre mit den
kommentaren letzten max mir geschickt
hat irgendwann video beschriebene
ernsthaft so psg schreit immer die haare
du hast einen zopf würde zwar auch
einmal auf warum er sich die haare
schneidet so so aus dem nichts als
gesamt opsource was man unbedingt weg
machen muss er schreibt wortwörtlich
einfach so schnell du doch mal die haare
junge ich denke so sänger fühle mich
okay nächste snap kommt von jobware
ich glaube es jetzt china
ein deutschlandtrikot dankeschön für die
zahlreichen snaps corine die orior frage
soll bestreichen nimmst du gesagt okay
das waren die fragen dann kann ich malen
und habe ich irgendwelche verträge sowie
im deutschland-trikot also ich kann
nicht malen 0
ich habe letztes mal eine folge gemacht
minecraft items malen da war ich
überraschend gut ehrlich gesagt niemals
niemals gedacht dass ich irgendwas
überhaupt marken oder so annähernd so
zeichnen kann das irgendwann es erkennt
ich will es gar nicht mal nennen
missbrauchs papier ist mit einem stift
nicht möglich die wahlen aber ich hab
euch die folge mal hier auf eine seite
verlinkt da können wir abschätzen wie
gut ich malen kann ich hoffe wie ist die
andere frage ob ich fan artikel ab ich
war früher vor sechs sieben jahren
relativ überzeugter fan von hertha bsc
das ist der größte fußballverein aus
berlin hat es der deutsche hauptstadt
vereine also eine friedliche und bei
hertha hatte da bin ich fan geworden als
er aufgehört momentan die methode für
audi war habe ich die fanartikel bund
tatsächlich hier härter trikot hertha
schal hat erfahren habe ich sogar um
auch noch und wie man einen vermuten
fußballfan taliban
den habe ich mir den zwei sekunden
ausgaben runter gerannt bin okay
verzeihten ich weiß aber schlecht aber
auch geil oder china was mach ich ja
diese mängel am tag
ich sitze eigentlich nur eine bude leute
ich mache nichts anderes im leben die
heute das was im heutigen wie ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen so weit
mein kleines experiment zum video wenn
sich gefallen als das schwert in die
kommentare
volckens nennt wie gesagt user apps capt
wir sehen uns morgen jemanden mio bis
dann haut rein macht torrentfreak